-Guys, do you ever see a photo
in the news and think,
"That headline should be
different"?
Well, we'll take care of that
right now.
It's time
for "News & Improved."
Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪ News & Improved ♪
[ Applause ]
-First example here.
Check out this first photo.
The original headline was...
The headline can definitely be
improved because,
if you only looked at the photo,
the headline could've been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Oh!
What?!"
-Up next, this headline says...
Yeah. The headline could've been
better. It could've been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Hi."
Next headline was...
[ Laughter ]
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Sanders ]
J...
...Q...
[ Laughter ]
The next headline was...
Headline could've have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Whoa!"
Next headline was...
Headline could've been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next headline is...
Headline could've been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally,
this headline was...
[ Laughter ]
The headline could've been..
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
That's all the time we have
for "News & Improved."